teachers who are being forced to teach
what they don't believe in they're
leaving and finding other jobs
parents who are
having kids go to school being forced to
learn something that they shouldn't
learn
they're deciding to listen honey you
better get a second job you better drive
uber at night our kids are going to
private school so that's number two so
public statement or they're voting on
the arizona voucher program which is so
hot perfect that's another round of
taking so so we have those two three you
got uh
individuals who are now being
asked to become teachers who are not
fully qualified to become teachers they
went to school you got the philosophies
being forced down their throat this this
is this is great let me explain to why
this is fantastic for me because this is
going to force people
uh to say okay this is what you want to
do no problem here's a route i'm going
to be taking if you think you're going
to be forcing more people to have the
philosophy of handouts you're going to
piss more and more and more people off
yesterday who's our uh biden's uh press
secretary what's her name uh karine
jean-pierre korin john pierre's being
asked about you know so you're okay with
uh kids you're okay with uh uh uh
immigrants crossing the illegal
immigrants crossing the border without
being vaccinated you're not even
checking them but you're worried about
you know novak you know coming to a u.s
open to play tennis yeah he says you
know did you hear her answer i heard it
did you hear what her answer her answer
was well we are not allowed to talk
about private medical situations of
people that are coming yeah i'm like
wait what how did you spend that one i
was so impressed about it she's good she
did that's their job though just spin
job but but that's listen spin is on
both sides but that spin was like you're
a goat of spinning right there
to do something like that so you know
but people are starting to sit around
and say if you live by the border you're
going to be like look man these people
are coming left and right and i don't
feel safe right now some people that are
coming over some people are going to sit
here they're democrats they voted for
this they're like what the hell is this
i busted my ass i'm not a democrat
because i want high taxes i'm a democrat
because i agree with let's just say a
person is a pro-choice or i'm a democrat
because i'm you know a social safety net
but i'm not okay with this bro what are
you doing i'm a working democrat so
they're creating enemies to the point
i love it we're a guy
who got americans to accept marijuana
through a podcast there was a netflix
down where he was the main guy on this
netflix show
joe rogan got people to say maybe weed
isn't that bad
he tells aaron
possibly a top five best quarterback of
all time
the solution is to vote republican yeah
what the hell are we talking about right
and elon musk says that here's a point
when when sometimes you're winning you
have blind spots you think you can
really manipulate everybody san
francisco voters you know what they said
yesterday san francisco people that live
in san francisco i'm not paying taxes
until you clean up the [ __ ]
people in san francisco are saying i am
not paying taxes until you clean up this
homelessness problem these are democrats
that are voting for those policies and
the needles it's slow
what you said about uh it's novak right
novak djokovic
if he spells n-o-v-a-s no yeah
no
he can't fly into the country to play a
tennis game but the border and why
doesn't he find the way to get to the
mexican border cross through there
that would be so funny he's coming
back
he's huge well all he has to do is take
a boat or just get air drop and just
walk through the border i mean he
doesn't have to be vectoring he's so
funny and he whips out his phone in san
diego gets an uber boom yeah and he's
there like this and like how did you get
here
but indeed it is quite offensive that
they're still demanding this is it new
york state is it is it uh the us open
specifically
is this the us government nfl still they
don't they're not messing around he's
obviously anybody coming over here to
play any sport or anything oh he he
cannot play and he's top two in the
world i think number one number one
right now so he's one of the three goats
the three goats of tennessee
who's
isn't that weird you know there's
another level of hypocrisy that's here
with the student loans and if you think
about it in the united states government
you have medicare right how many people
have a person in their life on medicare
your dad my mom your dad right my mom
yeah your mom excuse me um and they can
tell you hey i went in and i was gonna
have a chest x-ray the doctor said 260
dollars
and he gets the thing back from nope the
rate for an x-ray is 181 dollars ever
see that so you the doctor bill is
augmented but our parents don't pay the
difference the doctor accepts the 181
yeah it's the same thing for dental
the only exception on federal
programs
is sallie mae and education they don't
they don't adjust the price they're and
only what sallie mae would have to do is
say i'm sorry the maximum per credit
hour we will pay is this
because that's how they do it in health
insurance that's how they do it in
dental care and that's how they do it in
the private sector and that's how they
do it in the public sector with medicare
they determine that within a certain
bound is the price sallie mae is the
only place and higher education is the
only one to get a get out of jail free
card yeah we're going to raise it 20
this year oh okay well then we'll just
put that on the loan here it's the only
place that happens yeah the you know
they keep accusing biden of playing
politics you're just playing politics
you're just well that's his job that's
exactly who played politics kind of a
politician so he is pandering to his
base he obviously he wants to sure up
the gen z vote let's say or the
millennial vote and this is a ploy or a
tactic to get them to say you know what
brian's actually doing something for me
you're right so do i agree with paying
off student loans no but do i understand
the philosophy of why he's doing it i
get it because it doesn't make an
inflate time it's making inflation
higher isn't it because we're
we're dumping more money sure there's a
part of the student loans that you could
argue we're never going to be paid back
you know our history major who's never
going to be making more than 30 grand a
year or something and they're probably
never going to be able to pay back part
of their student loan which is another
discussion right yeah
what what are you underwriting stem or
you're underwriting liberal arts
are you um what percentage of uh
college degrees are just
completely useless in your opinion i
don't know if we have enough time for
that
i would say there's a lot of it but i
look at it this way
pbd what if we made a simple
valuetainment public service
announcement commercial
banker sits across from student
yeah i'd like 80 thousand dollars 20 a
year
to state college but i'm getting a
degree in art history well great um
i'm looking here at the um
jobs and what an art history maker will
make
and um i can't underwrite this why
because according to this it would take
you 40 years to pay it back
if you
still kept the student loan payment
higher than your rent or your house
payment eventually
oh and put this awareness out there do
you see what i mean yeah it would be an
underwriting and it's not the banker
being bad the bankers simply say i can't
underwrite that
i can't underwrite this transaction but
what if he goes excuse me though joe
biden's president now he promised that
he's going to forgive so does that
does that trade my like can i get it he
said 20 grand is going to be gone will
you give me the loan well if 20 years
from now the u.s president forgives half
of it and that's sort of a guarantee for
the bank then the bank could build that
in an underwriter but yeah tom you
actually bring up a great point here i
know you were kind of being a realist
but also a little bit sarcastic i don't
know if people got tom's humor he was
kind of imagining but you do have a good
point here and the point that i think
you were making is what's the roi on
your investment in yourself and that's
what somebody who is 18 has to figure
out and that's
most 18 year olds could not tell you
what roi is but when you go to college
you're investing in yourself and your
future
income right you're getting a a degree
that will hopefully put you in a better
position to make more money in your
lifetime and when you're 18 years old
it's a very difficult decision to make
all right what do you want to do the
rest of your life you're like bro i'm
just trying to [ __ ] get laid
everybody well that's a difficult
situation to figure out
scam what no it's a four-year social
experience that's the truth that's it
there kids are not going to get a better
degree and solidify their future you ask
10 kids i guarantee you trying to hook
up seven out of 10 kids say i'm going
for the experience i'm willing i'm going
to meet friends i'm going with a coach
well that's a good side of course if a
person's going if a person is going for
the social experience i'm willing to bet
you're going to party 10 times harder in
the military than you would if you want
to go 1 000 i'm willing to bet that
uniform is going to get you a 100 times
more play
where the uniform this is to take it off
and go to the mallet
you go to the changing room and gap and
yeah it's either asu or fsu or san diego
state san diego state yeah it's what
you're saying you're right that just
sent them out things all wrong buffalo
bills what kind of a precedent does this
set right what so we're teaching these
kids that you can take out 80 grand 100
grand 120 000 in debt and we're gonna
forgive it no no no no no
ten to twenty thousand so let's get the
number you can't just you're not there
no just forgiving 100 grand hang on this
is so just get the numbers right as well
this is just the beginning i would bet
that they're going to keep pushing to
forgive more and more and more of it
okay but what's the next elizabeth
warren yeah by the way you you can't be
naive to think this is not going to
continue
like you know people are about to get
another 1600 check i think times two
whatever the number is going to be
again this is five years ago we would
have been like what are you doing where
are they doing that though what do you
mean i think california's doing it i
think several states yeah
first of all i don't support that i mean
either i'm not one that's sitting there
saying do that i've never been a part of
this uh ubi uh concept that's becoming a
norm everywhere i'm in that conversation
with andrew i'm really a fan of that i'm
not the only time if you're going to
shut down restaurants
that is my way of making money
you i'm not in business because of you
you so you if you tell me i can't go to
work dude you better pay my bills that's
the difference that's a different story
but for you to just send out money
so going back to tyler i want you to
finish your thought going back to tyler
they're not gonna just do 10 20 thou
wait till two years from now they're
going to say this should work do it
again and again and again but then where
do they go next
housing
they claim housing is a human right so
they're going to forgive your housing
are they going to give the for loan
forgive the loan you take out on a house
and this okay this is completely
unconstitutional nancy pelosi is on
camera saying joe biden does not have
the power to do this the congress
controls the purse okay so you think
he's going to stop at colleges of course
not proof by the senate by the way right
so i watched this video with a guy i
think his name was uh p peterborough
david maybe oh pat patrick bet dave yeah
a
every dollar guaranteed in student loans
the price goes up by 60 cents so what
are they going to do after this they're
going to keep raising the price raising
the price raising the price raising the
price raised in the price katja has a
question too because i'm i'm not that
bright in this field
who are they how far back are these
loans getting forget like who's how far
does it go back how many people how many
people they're giving these these loans
to yeah
starting next year
you're not being forgiven but everybody
will probably oh wow that's a lot of
current current people you know the
total that it came out to be all this
money five hundred billion dollars three
hundred billion three hundred billion
which is used which used to be a large
number but now every single bill
anything that happens this is a trillion
that's what the truth 300 billion is a
lot of a lot of money i agree 300 but it
printing press that we have over at the
department of treasury now yeah it's
it's pretty pathetic what's going on
with this so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]